but the incredible thing about you
i i just uh recently talked uh spent a
couple days with jimmy pedro
and uh he talked about
his guys and just champions in general
hating to lose more than they love
winning
and the way you talked about losing you
lost very few times in your career like
later you you were dominating both the
wrestling and
mma but the way you took these losses
against people that are
i don't know
below elite level
that's fair uh
i was gonna get pissy but enough that's
completely fair
i thought he was a bum too no that's not
what i meant i'm in trouble it's okay no
it's good no no
no no but like what can you explain the
psychology behind that like the what
is is there a system behind this is
there philosophy behind this well i i
wasn't very good
in the beginning and i think i think
that's where all starts up so i didn't
start getting good until the age of like
13. i started at five i probably started
competing more at age 10 11.
i didn't really get good till 13 it's
still at 13 i'm i'm i'm great i'm
getting better right i'm pretty good um
so i actually i've actually i have
writing this book on sports psych but
this it's i got well i got someone right
for me kind of thing because i've had
this philosophy for years that there's
there has to be this balance between two
things right so on the one hand in this
category on the one hand you have hating
to lose a great champion has to hate to
lose like you said right but on this
other hand you have to have
someone who seeks out challenges right
because if you don't have that you're
never gonna reach your full potential
either and so you have to balance these
two balls
at the same time right and so like for
me i always and this is maybe because i
wasn't good but i was always like let me
go find the best people to wrestle all
the time let me go find i would like
literally uh like seven days ago when i
was starting to get better it was like
end decision internet well there was no
one was using the internet it was like a
wrestling magazine and like hey dad
there's a tournament here i think that
other kids gonna be there can you take
me two hours across the state today
please
you would wrestle like in competition
against them not competition yeah yeah
in competition hey i heard there's this
tournament here's the magazine says this
tournament hey dad will you take me over
there tomorrow you you weren't trying to
win you were trying to get the
experience i was trying to wrestle the
best guys maybe i win maybe i lose
there's no when you do a competition
there's no guarantee of a win or a loss
you're just doing competition right so i
wanted to go i wanted to challenge
myself against the best guys
of which i thought maybe i could come
out on top right so like eighth grade
year
i won way way you know i probably lost a
handful of times in the state of well
state wisconsin was probably really
really minimal the amount of times i
lost you know but it was just about
getting the challenge and it's like some
some kids
and not kids in my club because i'll
push them very hard on this are scared
of challenging themselves they like
being the big fish in this small pond
they're not willing to go say i'm i want
to go get that guy and i want to get
that guy and i want to get that guy and
so that's like so i think that's part of
it for me is like i always just loved
the challenge i enjoyed competing
thoroughly right and i understood from a
young age because it wasn't very good
losing's a part of it you're not always
going to win
you